why aren't there more massively
multiplayer shooters the answer of
course is quite simple they're really
difficult to make I recently talked with
james mccauley executive producer of
firefall who shared with me some of the
trials and tribulations of making a
persistent world shooter I guess it
makes sense then that firefall has been
in a beta state since 2011 but all betas
must end sometime even fire falls
seemingly perpetual testing phase and so
end it does on July 29 when red five
officially removes the beta tag and the
game is fully released clearly firefall
has been a long time coming the idea
started in 2006 with red fives dream of
taking high action combat and mobility
and taking it to a massive open world
and based on what I saw a fire falls
release version the game seems poised to
set itself apart from other animal
shooters planetside 2 is all about
competitive battles defiance is all
about player versus environment missions
and cooperation firefall offers both
types of gameplay wrapped up in a
colorful world that's built for vertical
exploration by a jump packs as well as
skander locomotion
as with most mmm oh jeez you choose a
class of sorts but in fire fall classes
are represented by battle frames these
are exoskeletons to which you equip
various weapons and skills what makes
battle frames distinct from typical mmog
classes is that you can equip any battle
frame you want thus changing classes
without having to create alternate
characters you can further customize
battle frames by leveling them up and
thus earning perks that further enhance
your frames and when you reach higher
levels you can install modules to
further modify your equipment firefall
will offer around 12,000 weapon
variations the experience begins with
taking missions and fighting the chosen
a race of aliens that emerged after
humanity created a disastrous energy
storm when attempting faster than light
travel your primary goal when entering a
new region is to uplink to a network
tower there by unlocking access to jobs
in the area enemies spawn points are not
hand placed instead the developers
designate which enemies are appropriate
for which areas and the game
procedurally spawns in features and
resources the chosen aren't your older
enemies and fireball however the game
will also feature of large-scale player
versus player battles focused on base
capture territory control and resource
collection red5 originally hoped to make
the game of competitive eSport but that
approach didn't work for firefall anyone
will be able to jump into fire falls PvP
and contribute to the battle but
competitive play is aimed at max level
players and read 5 plans on building on
it in the months and years to come when
firefall launches on the 29th the size
of the game versus its most recent beta
build will quadruple and will offer 15
times the amount of contest I haven't
played the beta personally since I was
waiting for full release and I'm glad
it's just around the bend based on what
I saw firefall might have been worth
wait gotcha